*sexy hair flip* WHAT'S UP?
Today...
I am... have a guest everybody! (i wonder who am the guest ;oo)
i'm- , i have a guest everybody
a surprise guest
A surprise guest...
that doesn't wanna come out apparently.
(*Marzia pops out of oblivion*) Pewds: We practiced this!
It's Marzia, everybody! :D *claps*
Pewds: Can you do this, Marzia?
M: No, I clearly cannot.
*sexy close-up shots*
P: Today I have a challenge for you, Marzia! (Whatcha up to now, Pewds?)
M: Mmhm, I'm ready (serious face) :3
Who is the best gamer?
*sigh*
Me :)
(That's all, folks!)
P: Which game are we playing?!
M: Dancing Line! <3
P: If you guys wanna check it out, we'll link it in the description.
Glorious sponsored video! Namaste!
M: Do you see my dancing top? *dances*
M: I prepared for this! *still dancing* Do you like it? :D
P: No one wants to see you dance, please stop. Stop immediately.
P: The point of this game... I never played it before.
M: *scoffs*
P: I haven't practiced.
P: But the point of the game is that you -- you sync it to the music.
M: Mmhm. P: So you gotta listen to the music.
M: Mmhm.
P: How would you say that your tempo...skill is? Level? (Nicely phrased, Pewds.)
M: Good! *giggles*
P: ...That's gonna be a tough one.
M: You haven't been practicing! P: Alright, here we go. You start, you start.
P: *clapping*  Whoever makes it first...
*music playing*
P: So it starts up really easy, okay? Don't worry about it.
*music playing, Pewds nodding along*
P: *faintly* So you gotta listen to the music...
M: Ugh!
P: 'Kay, you got twenty percent -- *is interrupted by Maya barking*
P: Maya! Gonna need you to shut up.
M: I'm like, do I still get points even if I don't hit it to the same time? P: You get less points.
M: Well, I'm still getting points. P: Uh-huh.
*music finishes*
P: Hey, you did it! Good job, Marzia! What's next for you? Sudooku, perhaps?
M: *disapprovingly* "Sodooku?"
P: *correcting himself* Sodoku.
P: Don't touch my nipple.
P: They have this new level called "The Faded", which -- you may have heard the song?
M: Mmhm.
P: Uhh, it's very emotional.
P: Even though technology has connected us more than ever, the whole world,
sometimes you feel more...disconnected and in solitude, than ever and this is what this song and this level is all about.
P: Listen, this is real hard, alright? M: *fails*
P: *snickering* M: 'Scuse me, where am I supposed to go?
P: *dying* M: Where am I supposed to go?!
P: THERE! XD
*music playing*
P: There you go, you got it.
*music playing* P: Ooh...
P: She's beginning to believe...
P: Where you going? Whoa!
P: That was sick!
P: She doesn't only play -- M: I'm so focused!
P: -- Sodoku. That's pretty good!
*music playing*
P: I feel...more and more disconnected, the more time it goes.
M: How are you so good?
P: It's called talent.
M: You even got the crystal!
*music playing*
P: Where am I going? This is so trippy!
M: Yeah... Whoa...
P: Whoo!
P: This is -- I feel empowered!
*game glitches* P: What?!
P: *distorted* THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE!
M: Ohhh -- P: Whoo!
P: That's tight, man.
M: Omg, it's only twenty percent?
*music playing*
*more upbeat music playing* P: Ooooooh!
P: No!
P: Dammit!
P: Oh, it was just getting good!
M: Oh, well, well...
M: Aww, Maya! I'll do it for you!
P (as Maya): "C'mon, you can do it, Marzia! I believe in you!"
*music playing*
M: Oops...
P (as Maya): "You suck, Marzia! What is wrong with you?!"
P: Next one! Up to me, alright?
P: This is for my bros...
*music playing, Marzia's hands dancing*
P: ...that stayed with me all this time!
*music playing*
P: ...And for my...
P: ...dog, Edgar...and maybe my dog, Maya.
P: And maybe Marz -- What're you doing?!
M: I'm making it dramatic!
P: *giggling* I can't hear you!
P: Oh!
*music playing*
P: OH!
P: Just gotta listen to the music, Marzia.
P: That's all you had to do.
*music playing*
P: *chuckling in amazement*
P & M: Whoa!
P: WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?!
M: You're missing all of them. P: Shh! Excuse me, I'm killing it!
M: Let me show you how it's done, boy! P: Okay...girl?
*music playing*
M: *silent laugh*
M: I got a crown!
P: Yeah, you're -- you're supposed to get the crown. *laughing*
M: Well, I'm saying... Did you get the crown?
P: I got all the crowns.
M: Didn't seem like it. P: 'Kay.
P: *dramatic gasp*
P: Oh!
M: Nooo! P: Ooooh!
P: Goodbye!
P: Why're you even trying?
P: Why're you even here? Just go --
P: *laughing*
M: It's a beachfront. P: Oh!
M: *dancing* P: Oh!
*music playing, Pewds showing his skills*
M: Are you even looking?
*music playing*
P: Oh! I actually did it!
P: That's pretty cool! M: You died!
P: Well, I know I died. M: Yeah, well. That's what counts.
P: Wasn't that awesome? M: No.
P: You just gotta believe...like Luke Skywalker.
M: Now I'm in between here...
*music playing*
P: Pfff!
P: *clapping* M: I didn't see it, okay?
M: I didn't see it!
M: Rude!
P: *randomly* You're so short! M: *offended*
P: *showing off*
*music playing*
P: Am I alive? M: Close your eyes!
P: Am I alive? M: Yep!
M: Oooh, you died.
*music playing*
M: *showing off her own skills*
P: She's beginning to believe!
P & M: *giggling*
M: Did I die?
P: Stop clicking, it's over!
P & M: *laughing*
P: What were you clicking to?
M: I don't know! I couldn't even hear the music!
M: I was just clicking!
P: *gasping* Ow, it hurts! My sides...!
P: Thank you for watching this video!
...
P & M: *giggling*
M: Aggressive..."THANK YOU FOR WATCHING THIS VIDEO!"
M: Hope you enjoyed it!
P: Check out "Dancing Line", link in the description. Super fun game!
P: I really enjoyed it. M: Mmhm.
P: I wanna try this last time, cos this is clearly the best song.
P: Closed eyes!
*music playing*
P: *fails without realizing it*
M: You're doing so good! ;)
P: *realization*
M: *laughing* P: I HATE YOU!
P: *whining* I'm not recording anymore!
P: *screams* M: Byeee!